fatal ist
für uns existenziell das ist das
wichtigste thema die wollen jetzt keine
kfw kredite und keine zuschüsse haben
die wollen eine absenkung der
energiepreise wie schnell können sie
diese versprechen was tun sie jetzt in
den nächsten wochen für den strombereich
ist es wenn ich das so sagen darf
vergleichsweise klar wie es geht wobei
das auch gesagt werden muss dass wir es
machen woran meine teams mit hochdruck
arbeiten ist eigentlich eine operation
für zwei jahre oder drei jahre wir
ändern das strommarkt design in
deutschland und das machen wir es in
wenigen wochen so dass wir das ist der
plan noch im jahr 22 die
wirkungsmechanismen
rückwirkend einsetzen können also die
preise dann quasi nachträglich senken
aber man muss auch klar sagen dass das
gefahr geneigt ist weil wir an das
system selbst dran gehen wir schöpfen
nicht oben irgendetwas ab und dann kann
man sich darüber unterhalten
fünf oder zehn prozent sollen beginn in
das system selbst rein
und deswegen kann man das eigentlich nur
rechtfertigen mit diesem
kriegswirtschaft zustand in dem wir sind
weil es nicht zu tun oder ist nicht zu
probieren noch fahrlässiger wäre aber
dass wir uns nicht missverstehen das ist
etwas was jeder verantwortungsvolle
politiker oder verbandsfunktionär
normalerweise mit einem zeitraum von
zwei jahren eingesetzt hätte und wir
machen das in wenigen wochen der
zeitplan ist aufgestellt wir wollen dass
in diesem jahr hinbekommen
wenn wir und ich würde sagen wir also
auch die unternehmerschaft
begründete zweifel haben dass das gut
genug durchgeprüft ist sollten wir dann
zurückfallen auf die option hier der
koalitionsausschuss auch gegeben hat
dann werden die strompreise so gesenkt
dass man bei den verschiedenen
energieträgern die sehr gute geschäfte
gemacht haben abschöpft und das dann den
unternehmen und den bürgerinnen und
bürgern zurück gibt das ist nicht die
preissenkung die würde dann erst in 23
jürgen aber es wäre dann wirkungsgleich
also wir sind mit hochdruck daran und
das ziel muss logischerweise sein dass
in 22 noch am ende des jahres im
gesetzblatt zu haben ob es gelingt wie
gesagt ist wie alles im moment
sehr anspruchsvoll vor wenigen wochen im
monat haben sie noch gesagt es gibt
keine strompreis problem das würden sie
heute nicht wiederholen mengenproblem
habe ich gesagt
und zwar bezogen auf die gaskrise also
das war ja die auf eis legen sie sind
das habe ich im deutschen bundestag
johann märz ihr gehört aber natürlich
kann man jeden satz auch gegen seine
intention stellen wenn man ihn aus dem
kontext löst damals haben wir darüber
gesprochen wie wir den gasverbrauch
unterkriegen und schon da ging es darum
ob die atomkraftwerke da einen beitrag
leisten und in dem kontext ist ersatz
gefallen und wenn man sich den
stresstest der jetzt ja vorliegt
anschaut also nicht nur anschaut sondern
vielleicht auch liest sieht man dass die
atomkraftwerke einen beitrag leisten
aber es noch geringer bei dem
gasverbrauch reduktion als wir es jemals
gedacht haben er ist im promillebereich
promillebereich ist auch ein bereich
völlig klar aber natürlich müssen wir
eine abwägung treffen wie bei so vielen
dingen also die eigentliche relevanz
frage für die atomkraftwerke wir auch
schon bei dem stresstest bei der
beauftragung geahnt ist die
netzstabilität in dem zusammenhang ist
das ist der satz gefallen und jetzt ist
die frage nach der strommenge so zu
beantworten wenn das europäische ausland
seine kapazitäten ans netz bringt
frankreich vor allen dingen die
atomkraftwerke und wir eine klimatische
verbesserung haben also die
kohlekraftwerke die wir in den markt
gegeben haben auch mit kohle versorgt
werden können wenn sich die
wasserreservoirs in den alpen auffüllen
dann haben wir das problem nicht wenn
wir und dann kann man die szenarien
hochrechnen ausfälle haben dann schlägt
das irgendwann auch nach deutschland
durch weil wir einen europäischen
strommarkt haben das heißt wir versorgen
das ausland mit und das ausland liefert
an uns je nachdem wie die
grenzkuppelstellen die man übertragung
zu lassen es geht auch gar nicht darum
ihnen alte zitate vorzuhalten das spiel
ist das immer gerne machen ja das macht
man muss die zitate glaube ich den text
lassen wie jeder journalist weiß das ist
immer richtig wir würden aus dem kontext
was zitieren herr habe deswegen trotzdem
noch mal die frage hat dieser
bundeswirtschaftsminister frühzeitig
genug dafür gesorgt dass aus dieser
energiekrise keine industrie krise wird
und dann frage ich mich wenn ich mehr
entlastungs paket anschaue warum da so
viele wenn dann konstruktionen drin sind
immer dann wenn es um die entlastung und
die maßnahmen für die wirtschaft gibt da
muss jetzt erst in europa eine wie auch
immer geartete zufalls gewinnen abgabe
gebaut werden damit das erste der
strompreis bremse kommt warum haben sie
in dieser runde nicht gesagt freunde die
energiepreise sind jetzt das thema ich
mache eine nationale strompreis wenn sie
ich setze die stromsteuer auf was auch
immer um jetzt zu entlasten wir warten
jetzt auf die strompreis bremse wann
kommt sie da habe ich ja gerade gesagt
bis ende des jahres das waren die ersten
drei männer sind nicht ausgelagert und
manch anderen fragen bedarf bedürfen
eines beschlusses des
koalitionsausschusses weil sie natürlich
haushalts relevant sind der es gegeben
worden und deswegen kann ich heute
ankündigen dass wir im rahmen der
industrie unterstützung das sind diese
verschiedenen programme die wir haben
die vorgaben nach meiner vorstellung
nach meinem vorschlag deutlich liberaler
gestalten werden also für die grand city
dämpfungs martin für die grundstufe ist
es im moment so aufgestellt dass die
kübel liste das ist die liste für die
für die handels intensiven unternehmen
einer logik folgen dass diese
unternehmen weil sie ja mit der
nationalen wettbewerb stehen ihre preise
nicht weitergeben können dann würde halt
das ausland übernehmen dass diese liste
jedenfalls für die grundstufe wegfällt
und
alternativ daneben mit den energiekosten
und den
prognostizierten gewinn ausfällen
kombiniert oder ersetzt werden kann
sodass man also nicht mehr nur handels
intensive unternehmen fördert durch das
energiekosten dämpfungs programm sondern
alle unternehmen die jetzt ein problem
bekommen aber natürlich dass sie das
kostet geld und das sind ja zuschüsse
die gewährt werden und über die summe
ist auch nicht eine einigung ist erzielt
worden aber natürlich brauchte ich um so
ein vorschlag jetzt machen zu können das
gros des koalitionsausschusses dass es
politisch gewollt ist und dass die
people liste davor oder die programme so
eng waren lag da liegt auch daran dass
wir mit den haushaltspolitischen
rahmenbedingungen umgehen mussten wenn
sie sagen schafft die stromsteuer
abschafft die netzentgelte ab würde ich
als energie und ich würde auch sagen als
klimaschutzminister sagen gerne denn
nichts kann uns im moment mehr helfen
als strom der dann ja zunehmend
erneuerbar wird günstig zu machen nur
kostet das gleich wieder zehn milliarden
und solange wir darüber einigung
erzielen und ich bin der meinung wir
sollten das tun dass sie jetzt nicht
kleckern sondern klotzen dass diese zehn
milliarden gut angelegt sind bin ich
sofort bereit das zu tun was für den
mittelstand wenn ich das sagen darf
ähnlich bisher war die annahme die
politische annahme aber auch eine
sparsamkeit sein name wenn ich so sagen
darf der mittelstand kann in der regel
so lange er nicht in den
wettbewerbsintensiven bestimmungen
beziehungen steht seine preise
weitergeben schlecht für die verbraucher
schlecht für die inflation aber
theoretisch möglich die preise
weiterzugeben die energiepreise weiter
zu geben nun sehen wir unter dem unter
dem unter dem hohen druck der inflation
die große kaufzurückhaltung die
konsumschwäche die daten zeigen ist
eindeutig dass diese
makroökonomische richtige herleitung
oder nachvollziehbare herleitung nicht
mehr mit der wirklichkeit übereinstimmen
deswegen werden wir auch ich gehe nach
gleich zum mittelstands gipfel die logik
dieser industrie förderlinie für den
mittelstand ausweiten dh der mittelstand
kann ebenfalls nach einem anteil der
kosten selber tragen muss
zuschüsse beantragen die dann gewährt
werden auf allen energieverbrauch damit
die unternehmen überleben und direkt
bezuschusst werden und das muss
natürlich das ist nur heilen das ist der
konsequenz des zentrums ist klar
im strombereich haben wir auch eine
antwort die habe ich grade skizziert für
die fossilen energieträger im gasbereich
haben wir diese antwort noch nicht weil
sie so kostenintensiv ist deswegen gibt
es erst einmal zuschüsse aber immerhin
ich werbe dafür dass es die gibt und ich
habe auch dafür dass wir auf der
nachfrageseite auf der konsum sollte
aber auch auf der seite der staatlichen
nachfrage also aufträge die der staat an
reizen kann jetzt keine fehler machen
und diesen krassen schock diesen terms
of trade shop dass wir ganz viele
milliarden euros ausgeben für das
ausleihen aber für unsere produkte die
wir ins ausland verkaufen nicht das
gleiche geld zurück kommen dass wir die
ängste überwinden durch die richtige
wirtschafts und finanzpolitik nämlich
die wirtschaft und die bevölkerung dabei
zu unterstützen die substanz
deutschlands zu erhalten den
mittelständischen betrieb der 30 oder 40
prozentige energiepreiserhöhungen
weitergeben kann in einem markt wo
ohnehin schon vorher die
industriestrompreise preise in
deutschland extrem hoch von denen
betrieb müssen sie uns mal nennen also
ich glaube das ist im theoretischen
alles klug und richtig in der praxis
schließen die inflationsrate gesagt
haben ich habe es oft gerade gesagt dass
die herleitung im sommer war dass man
bei unternehmen die ihre preise
weitergeben können noch nicht staatlich
unterstützen muss das aber die situation
sich über den herbst so verändert hat
oder über den sommer so verändert hat
dass das genau wie sie sagen jetzt nicht
mehr geht es steht nur noch im lehrbuch
die leute kaufen nicht mehr ein sie
halten das geld zurück die nachfrage
sinkt das geschäftsklima der
geschäftsklimaindex geht runter deswegen
gilt diese akademische logik nicht und
sie muss gebrochen werden mit massiven
staatlichen unterstützung zurück oder
sie gehen sie haben über den
nachfrageschock gesprochen auch im
bundestag vergangene woche oder sie
gehen doch noch mal ans angebot an weil
das ist der erste schock den wir erlebt
haben ist der angebotsschock und sagen
na ja wir müssen doch schauen ob wir
nicht energie bekommen und deswegen
würde ich schon gerne noch mal eine
sekunde mit ihnen über die mit atomkraft
leben sie sagen promillebereich
vielleicht sind meine informationen
falsche weiter gas einsprachen caprica
machen ja schon egal das richtige
zitieren ja hab gesagt die die bedeutung
der akw s gas einzusparen ist geringer
als gedacht aber die bedeutung der akw s
für eine energie sicherheit und für eine
energie kostenentlastung die es aus
meiner sicht größer als es vielleicht in
ihrer entscheidung am ende zum tragen
kommt weil wenn ich sehe dass ein akw
1,4 gigawatt strom leisten kann das in
zehn millionen haushalte frage ich mich
und sie zu recht ja sagen jede kilowatt
zählt egal ob jetzt gas oder strom
werden eine energiekrise den unternehmen
ist und zweifel ja egal ob sie zu viel
gas bezahlen zu viel strom sie brauchen
entlastungen bei dem thema energie dann
hätte ich doch gesagt wir machen diese
akw so lange es irgendwie möglich ist
und wenn sie nur ein prozent reisepreis
steigerungen dämpfen können ist es das
dach doch wert also wie sie im moment
sehen laufen der die akw s und die reise
sind trotzdem hoch sie jetzt etwas
runter werden sonst noch viele ja sehr
viel höher ist relativ man muss
verstehen wie der strommarkt
funktioniert der preisbildung
funktioniert und was dann das richtige
instrument ist ich will mich um die akw
frage gar nicht um schummeln ich will
nur dass für die richtige debatte führen
und der strommarkt das werden alle
inzwischen wissen baut sich so auf dass
immer die günstigsten energieträger
reingehen das sind vor allem in der
regel die erneuerbaren aber atomstrom
auch und dann baut sich der verlor
langsam auf und die jeweils höchsten
setzen den preis das sind in der regel
die gaskraftwerke wenn man den sockel
etwas an liebt dann hat man die
differenz zwischen teuren gaskraftwerk
und ganz toll und gaskraftwerk das ist
der unterschied aber da wollen sie
herein das akw theoretisch machen könnte
unterstellt die brennelemente würden
noch lange laufen sonst reden wir halt
über unterschiede für die nächsten drei
oder vier monate das problem lösen wir
durch den abbau der über gewinne wie ich
gerade gesagt habe insofern stellt sich
aus meiner sicht also die kostenfrage
muss anders in den griff bekommen werden
weil der unterschied zwischen teuren
gaskraftwerke und ganz teuren
gaskraftwerk am ende nicht die
entlastung bringt auf die hier alle
warten und die deutschland braucht nicht
das worüber wir reden ja und wo die akw
es eine rolle haben aber eben auch nur
eine rolle neben anderen ist die
netzstabilität ja unter den bedingungen
dass das europäische ausland frankreich
der alpenraum nicht genug strom für die
netzspannung bereitstellen kann da haben
sie eine rolle aber wie gesagt nur eine
rolle noch mal um es ins verhältnis zu
setzen unter den stress szenarien also
den der annahme dass frankreich nicht
das schafft was sie angekündigt haben 50
gigawatt ans netz zu bringen moment sind
23 dort unter der annahme dass die
gaskraftwerke in deutschland und damit
im alpenraum nur 50 prozent laufen dann
ist eine unterversorgung gibt unter der
annahme dass die kohlekraftwerke
ebenfalls nur 50 prozent energie
kapazität bereitstellen weil es auch im
november und dezember nicht regnet und
der rhein einfach die transportkapazität
nicht hat unter dieser annahme entsteht
eine stromlücke zwischen vier bis acht
gigawatt
die geschlossen werden was für die
netzstabilität und die atomkraftwerke
alle drei ein bisschen gestuft danach wo
sie liegen können von dieser stromlücke
von vier bis acht 0,5 schließen die
lücke ist so groß dass ich sage wir
können keinen keine alternative jetzt
fahrlässig aus der hand geben aber sie
ist eben auch so groß dass die
atomkraftwerke alleine diese lücke eben
gar nicht schließen können 0,5 zu vier
bis acht und das ist die relevante frage
die wir eigentlich diskutieren das ist
das ergebnis des stresstest ist und
deswegen ich weiß dass das
wahrscheinlich auch hier in diesem saal
nicht populär ist aber als ich minister
wurde habe ich mir geschworen nicht die
populären entscheidungen zu treffen
sondern die angemessen und die richtigen
deswegen war ich gegen einen gas embargo
und deswegen bin ich gegen stimmen in
meinem milieu die sagen packt die
atomkraftwerke werk wir wollen das nicht
steht auch am gesetz aber ich sage auch
eine
ein aufbau einer argumentation die sagt
die atomkraftwerke sind unsere lösung
wird der komplexität und auch der
aufgabe die wir wirklich lösen müssen
nicht gerecht habe ich werde diesen kurs
weiter machen dass ich mich entlang von
fakten hierdurch halte und nicht und
nicht dem zuruf folge
[Applaus]
ich finde auch sie müssen dann korrekt
zitieren der habe ich kenne niemanden
der sagt die ak w sind die lösung ich
kenne aber viele die sagen unter einem
veronika grimm die mitglied im
sachverständigenrat ist die sagen sie
kann ein teil der lösung im januar
februar märz sein und das was sie jetzt
machen mit der notfallreserve seit die
schlechteste aller lösungen und das
zufällig das niedersächsische akw nicht
in die notfallreserve kommt hat auch
nichts mit dem wahlkampf in
niedersachsen zu tun sagen sie naja der
nets engpass ist im süddeutschen raum er
hat sich leicht von ostmark von nord
nach ost west verschoben weil die
strommengen jetzt richtung frankreich
laufen das könnte sich wieder drehen der
normale netz engpass liegt weiter
südlich weil wir eine
nord-süd-verbindung eigentlich haben
aber das hat sich jetzt vielleicht
verändert emsland ist weit weg das heißt
die haupt wirklich sagen nicht das
emsland gar kein beitrag leistet aber
ich sagte schon bei der netzstabilität
das ist ja die aufgabe die wir lösen
müssen ist die aufgabe
potenziell eine lücke von 4 bis 8
gigawatt zu schließen alle drei akw s
haben 0,5 anteil davon das kann man
aufsplitten auf die jeweiligen akw s das
haben die netzbetreiber oder die
übertragungsnetzbetreiber leider nicht
getan aber nach den studien oder nach
den gesprächen das ist ja nicht
gerechnet worden die ich habe ist der
anteil von emsland nicht ein drittel ein
drittel ein drittel sondern noch
geringer weil ist eben nicht da liegt
was nicht und deswegen und das ist ja
nun mal leider zuzugeben dass atomkraft
und die frage wie damit umgehen aus
meiner sicht eine abwägungsentscheidung
ist es sind als eine
hochrisikotechnologie das wird glaube
ich niemand bestreiten die darauf
ausgelegt wurde den leistungsbetrieb
jetzt zu beenden und entsprechend wurden
die akw es auch gefahren deswegen
sage ich für mich keine ideologische
blindheit und keine seite aber eine
abgewogene entscheidung unter der
bewertung der risiken und das ist der
grund warum emster nicht dabei ist und
immerhin haben wir doch jetzt sogar ein
endlager gefunden in europa das wird in
südbaden württemberg seien ja aber das
deutsche atomgesetz sagt dass in der
schweiz aber dass ich sagen you
württemberg wenn das zu sagen jaja
imperialistische zug ist aber egal
dachte herr kretschmann und sagt dann
jetzt neuer dicke steine werden an der
grenze wahrscheinlich nicht anders sagen
jetzt haben wir über endlagerstandort
geflogen wo sie ein ernstes thema
ansprechen die endlagersuche ist
ungelöst
deutschland hat im atomgesetz stehen wir
dürfen den atommüll nicht nicht
exportieren also wir können die nicht in
die ukraine oder nach russland und nach
china verkaufen außer wir ändern das
atomgesetz aber das wäre natürlich dann
auch
wir exportieren unsere probleme weil wir
nicht in der lage sind sie selber zu
lösen das ist eine haltung die mir sehr
unangenehm ist also müssen wir dieses
endlager suchen
es soll bis 2030 gefunden sein bis 2050
ertüchtigt und dann sagen experten
braucht man noch ungefähr 30 jahre bis
alle castoren eingelagert sind also wenn
mich meine kinder fragen robert was
machen werde ich mit dem atommüll müsste
ich sagen gute nachricht ende des
jahrhunderts haben wir das problem
gelöst so massiv ist das problem weil es
natürlich keine bereitschaft gibt sich
an diesem prozess konstruktiv zu
beteiligen alle sagen nur immer weiter
laufen zu lassen ist super aber in
meinem wahlkreis mit der ein endlager
wenn es geeignet ist habe ich noch von
keinem gehört und schon gar nicht wenn
ich diese spitze noch los werden darf
habe ich es aus bayern gehört weil und
auch das muss man sich mal auf der zunge
zergehen lassen wie hier wie hier
versucht wird eine debatte zu nutzen
weil das deutsche endlagersuchgesetz
sagt ganz deutschland ist erstmal
neutraler suchraum das haben alle länder
im bundesrat mit abgestimmt das ist teil
dieses land kommt konsens gewesen und
dann sagen experten wo ist der
geeignetste suchen
nur markus söder weiß schon und sagt
dass auch dass er nicht in bayern sein
wird und jetzt frage ich mich wie will
man irgendeinem landrat irgendeinem
bürgermeistern in das wird ja unangenehm
wir sind ja mitten in dem prozess und
den nächsten zwei jahren werden
vorschläge kommen und sagen da oder da
oder da könnte ein endlager sein und
dann ist doch klar was passiert wenn man
sich die debatte anschaut alle werden
sagen um gottes willen bloß sich und
wahrscheinlich einen gutteil der
menschen die sagen lasst doch die
atomkraftwerke jetzt länger laufen sagen
und gottes willen bloß nicht bei uns und
dann muss irgendein bürgermeister sich
da hinstellen und sagen das ist
vielleicht eine unangenehme entscheidung
aber wenn ist der sicherste standpunkt
standort ist dann muss das halt bei uns
sein anders kommen wir hier nicht durch
und wie man das von irgendeinem
bürgermeister für an verlangen wenn
jemand der bundeskanzler werden wollte
und ministerpräsident ist noch nicht mal
den mumm hat das für sein zu machen ich
kann der wird auch dafür bezahlt
verantwortung zu übernehmen deswegen
finde ich finde ich in dieser debatte
in dieser debatte läuft einiges ganz
schön schief ich scheue mich nicht die
verantwortung auch für die schwierigen
und vielleicht auch manchmal für die
entscheidung zu übernehmen die nicht
eins zu eins sofort auf gegangen sind
weil ich habe schon beim strom hat
gesagt wir arbeiten unter hochdruck und
wir machen sachen die nicht im
koalitionsvertrag stehen wie hat sich
das land auf sowas vorbereiten können
und meine leute auch nicht aber dann
gehört auch dazu dass man die
verantwortung übernimmt und sagt dann
macht man das ich tue das aber ich
erwarte dass von allen anderen auch und
wenn sich jetzt der nächste wird
politiker hinstellt und sagt weiter
laufen lassen der atomkraftwerke wird es
nur dann ein glaubhaftes argument wenn
er sagt und im zweifelsfall auch in
meinem wahlkreis endlager können wir
gleich besprechen ja aber ich glaube sie
haben ihren punkt gemacht
sie haben ihren punkt gemacht sie haben
die strompreis bleiben sie bis ende des
jahres angekündigt sie haben zugegeben
wir sind wohl vor im vorabend einer
rezession das thema gas bevor ich ganz
kurz mitglieder des bettelarmen sie
verhindern ja eine sage wir können sie
verhindern natürlich also es wird schwer
und anspruchsvoll aber eine rezession
ist ja kein natur aber dann müssen wir
über den gaspreis deckel dann doch mal
müssen jetzt sind wir müssen einen
maßnahmen step machen wir müssen die
energie preise runter bringen wir müssen
die nachfrageseite stärken es ist ja
eine konsumschwäche das hätten die leute
genug geld und vertrauen dass das geld
nicht aus kann sie würden auch weiter
kaufen wir müssen die unternehmen die
wirtschaftsunternehmen in ihren
investitionsentscheidungen
unterstützen dass sie nicht das geld
zurückhalten und sagen das könnte ja
noch schwieriger werden sondern genug
vertrauen in die staatliche feuerkraft
haben zu sagen da wollten wir erweitern
bauen investieren transformieren das
machen wir jetzt auch weil es eine
zukunft gibt das heißt wir haben
politisch alle instrumente sind schon
längst darüber an die kollegen werden
umwelt ich sie aber steht leider links
die zeit und ich will damit sagen eine
rezession ich hab ich ja gesagt wenn die
daten sofort geschrieben werden dann
laufen wir in eine rezession aber eine
rezession ist kein gewitter das auf uns
zu ziehen und wir können wir entscheiden
haben wir einen regenschirm oder laufen
wir weg wir können natürlich dagegen
anarbeiten wenn wir jetzt ernsthaft
darüber diskutieren wirtschaftshilfen
energiepreis bremse die richtigen
politischen maßnahmen das
konjunkturklima anreiz und die
binnennachfrage stärken
dann können wir sie natürlich auch
abwenden oder zumindestens kurz halten
oder vielleicht dämpfen das sind ja
alles möglichkeiten und deswegen gut
dass sie heute darüber diskutieren da
geb ich habe hier sparen jetzt nicht
schnell noch eine kleine ganz kurze
frage aus dem saal aus der audienz und
dann mit der bitte um eine kurze antwort
und dann ist das sicher zu ende märz
abbitte
in der altenpflege wurde dieses jahr
eine kostenlawine losgetreten aber wo
bleiben die entlastung wir sind nicht
inkludiert in den entlastungs raketen
die energiekosten steigen die löhne
steigen weg an pflege bezahlbar bleiben
aber die chance gebe ich ihnen jetzt
darauf noch sagen ja ich habe es ja
schon gesagt die energiekosten
übernehmen wir anteilig und ich gehe es
hier gleich in dem mittelstands gipfel
ich habe überlegt ob ich es hier heute
zahlen daten fakten laufzeiten nenne ich
glaube es ist gut ja geld den verbänden
eben nicht weil es glaube ich gut ist
mit den verbänden zu diskutieren und
nicht zu sagen wir wissen alles besser
das dauert halt fünf tage länger aber
ist wenn jugend habe ich nicht allzu
erhellende digitalen und
mittelstandskunden in ihrem hause daran
liegt eigentlich sehr gut also ich kann
ja sagen wie ich es mir vorstelle wir
legen einen kuchen fest wie hoch der
energieverbrauch energieintensiv ist
möglichst niedrig 3% vielleicht dann
sagen wir dass ein großer anteil selbst
getragen werden muss so ist es bei kübel
bei dieser liste in dem programm auch
aufgelegt und darüber hinaus gibt es ein
prozent anteil den der staat übernimmt
und dann muss man schauen wie hoch ist
der prozentanteil und wand hängt man ihn
an zu kombinieren mit verlusten meiner
ansicht nach sollten wir für die kmu s
also klassische mittelstand nicht noch
einfordern dass eine verlustrechnung
gibt sondern großzügig sein weil die
kleineren unternehmen nicht
quartalsweise schauen wie wie genau sie
da stehen das wird auch administrativ
erwarten seien aber das ist natürlich
politisch zu diskutieren und auch
irgendwann eine gerechtigkeitsfrage
denken sie an die gasanlage
und die unternehmen die gewinne gemacht
haben und die umlage bekommen wenn wir
jetzt alle sagen ja super machen wir
sodann sind dabei auch unternehmen die
gewinne machen grundsockel selber tragen
50 prozent energiekosten zuschuss ohne
zu prüfen ob die unternehmen verluste
oder gewinne machen ist sehr großzügig
und das wird eine debatte darüber geben
fördert ihr nicht die falschen mit
meinem steuergeld oder mit meinen
schulden oder mit den schulden die ich
dann abtragen muss darüber ist zu
sprechen ich bin der meinung in der
situation auch mal fünfe gerade sein
lassen pauschal und großzügig aber das
kostet alles geld das geld muss wieder
erwirtschaftet werden es muss wieder
aufgebracht werden und es gibt eine
gerechtigkeitsfrage natürlich können wir
auch sagen wir machen nicht die gesamten
kmu s 250 mitarbeiter sondern nur bis
irgendeine zahlen und danach muss eine
verlust- abrechnung vorliegen könnte man
auch machen wird kompliziert nicht nötig
aus meiner sicht aber darüber ist zu
reden deswegen ich habe einen ich habe
eine idee wie ich es machen würde finde
es aber gut wenn wir zumindestens die
woche geben um mit den mittelstand zu
wenden mit dem unter allen den
arbeitgeberverbänden den gewerkschaften
entgegen auch darüber zu reden wie
machen wir es denn jetzt sollen dann am
ende muss noch eine einigung in der
regierung geholt werden vielen dank herr
minister habe für diesen schnellen ritt
durch die wichtigen themen vielen dank
dass sie hier waren bis zum nächsten mal
markante stimme
an was ja
meine sehr verehrten damen modernen tut
mir leid dass ich etwas überzogen habe
das wird selbstverständlich diese
nachspielzeit werden die folgenden
gesprächsteilnehmer selbstverständlich
auch bekommen herr kampeter muss das bei
seiner moderation nachher dann wieder
rausholen diese zeit ich freue mich sehr
dass er heute hier ist und jetzt direkt
auf einige dieser themen auch vielleicht
etwas wichtiges beitragen kann der
fdp-vorsitzende und vor allem der
bundesfinanzminister der bundesrepublik
herr lindner herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
robert habeck hat gerade gesagt die
strompreis bremse kommt sie wird teuer
werden sie kostet auch geld sie wollte
uns aber er wollte uns aber nicht
verraten wie viel geld am ende in die
entlastung für die haushalte und
mittelständische unternehmen gegeben
wird können sie uns das verraten nein
weil es ist ja kein geld aus dem
bundeshaushalt das hier vorgesehen ist
sondern wir haben ein instrument gewählt
dass im strommarkt selbst wirken soll
das heißt die politisch gemachten regeln
sorgen ja jetzt gegenwärtig dafür dass
die erzeuger von strom aus sonne und
wind und kohle und kernkraft hohe
zufalls gewinne erreichen weil
abgerechnet wird nach dem merit order
prinzip als hätten sie gas verstromt und
hier arbeiten wir mit einer erlös
obergrenze und wollen damit die privaten
haushalte und auch die wirtschaft
unterstützen zum beispiel indem in
milliarden größenordnung die
netzentgelte reduziert werden aber es
ist ausdrücklich keine steuerrechtliche
maßnahme ausdrücklich außerhalb des
bundeshaushalts eine maßnahme im
strommarkt starten sie eine ergänzung
robert habeck hat hier eben wie ich fand
sehr eindringlich das ergebnis des
physikalischen stresstestes bei der
energieerzeugung dargestellt nach meiner
überzeugung brauchen wir aber auch einen
ökonomischen
stresstest bei der erzeugung von energie
und ihren preisen und jeden beitrag
knappheiten zu reduzieren durch planbare
energieerzeugung aus kohle und kernkraft
jeden beitrag sollten wir erhalten denn
das sind beiträge nicht nur zur
physikalisch netzstabilität sondern auch
das an der strombörse der preis im
nächsten jahr sinkt ja billiger denn
[Applaus]
wir kommen wir kommen auf die atomkraft
noch noch die frage herr minister heute
gab es einen ersten entwurf führt diese
zufalls gewinn erlös abschöpfung abgabe
wie auch immer man sie offiziell
bezeichnen darf ohne ärger in der
eigenen koalition zu bekommen jedenfalls
wurde dort gesagt ein drittel der
gewinne dieser über gewinne soll
abgeschöpft werden als mindest standard
in allen europäischen staaten und dann
können die nationalstaaten weiter
darüber hinaus gehen ist das ein modell
was jetzt bei ihnen diskutiert wird
das muss der herr kollege robert habeck
entscheidend wie gesagt es hat uns ja
nicht um eine steuerrechtliche maßnahme
sondern was wir beabsichtigen ist eine
im bereich der energiewirtschaft
sie haben sondern nebenbei bemerkung
gemacht um in der koalition keinen ärger
wie man das bezeichnet also die sind
wirklich nicht in der lage wo wir so
kleinteilig parteipolitisch diskutieren
wo regelrechte strömungsabriss in der
deutschen wirtschaft zu befürchten ist
ich sage nur eins die über
gewinnbesteuerung über die manche
sprechen hat in italien nicht dazu
geführt dass hohe einnahmen erzielt
worden wären sondern viele klagen gegen
den staat sind erhoben worden und
deshalb ist der weg auf den wir uns
verständigt haben keiner der
gesichtswahrung von koalitionspartnern
sondern einer der planbare einnahmen
erzielt um diejenigen die strom
verbrauchen zu entlasten er bewies der
zeitablauf jetzt wie schnell geht das
bis tatsächlich bei denen unternehmen
die jetzt schon der produktion verlagern
teilweise stilllegen oder vorübergehend
schließen soll was ankommt so schnell
wie möglich aber ich kann jetzt nicht
öffentlich dem dem fachlich zuständigen
kabinettskollegen
fristen setzen aber wo ich ihn bat
erwartungen kann würde ich einen beitrag
leisten kann tue ich das es muss so
schnell wie möglich sein aber ihr
beitrag wäre ja zu sagen ja ich habe 50
milliarden euro steuermehreinnahmen in
diesem jahr durch die inflation ich habe
einige milliarden steuermehreinnahmen
bei der einkommensteuer ich bin bereit
alles die summe iks dafür auszugeben um
bei den strom- und gaspreisen am ende
bürger und haushalte und unternehmen zu
entlasten
zusätzlichen einnahmen die der bund
dieses jahr erzielt hat sind längst an
die bürgerinnen und bürger und die
betriebe zurückgegeben worden ich habe
das gefühl manche betriebe spüren dass
nicht wir haben volkswirtschaftlich
keine mehreinnahmen die wir im
bundeshaushalt haben sondern über die
entlastungs paket geht alles zurück und
insofern ist die vorstellung davon der
staat würde sich in diesem jahr an der
inflation bereichern leider unrichtig da
haben wir alles was wir an zusätzlichen
einnahmen haben längst über die
entlastungs paket zurück aber mit der
inflation konnten sie ja auch nicht
rechnen die haben ja auch für nächstes
selbst verstanden einnahmen
selbstverständlich das haben wir ja auch
die die entlastungs paket in diesem jahr
gemacht aber im nächsten jahr geht es
weiter in der tat es ist eine
inflationsbedingte einnahmensteigerung
zu erwarten und deshalb wird der
spitzenausgleich für energieintensive
betriebe ein weiteres jahr verlängert
der wäre zum ersten erst 2023
ausgelaufen morgen im bundeskabinett
beschließen wir dass das verlängert wird
wie hoch es im nächsten jahr ist ein
milliarden betrag
im nächsten jahr wird es im übrigen auch
ja eine beseitigung der ansonsten drohen
kalten progression geben das sind nach
den jetzigen zahlen 10 milliarden euro
ich ahne wenn der progression bericht in
wenigen wochen vorliegt wird das noch
signifikant nach oben korrigiert werden
weil mein
inflationsausgleichs gesetz im entwurf
ebenfalls morgen im kabinett geht ja
noch auf die frühjahrsprognose zurück in
der herbstprognose werden der andere
inflationszahlen sehen und der brücke
hat dass das ist ein echter beitrag um
inflationäre entwicklungen weiter zu
reduzieren
dann überlegen sie mal es gebe jetzt
tarifabschlüsse von arbeitgebern und
gewerkschaften und am ende würde der
finanzminister profitieren weil durch
die kalte progression die beschäftigten
belastet werden das war ein harter kampf
sie haben das in den medien verfolgt wie
das denunziert worden ist teilweise
dabei finde ich es nur gerecht wenn in
diesem jahr das mittlere einkommen
43.000 euro sind und die 43.000 euro im
nächsten jahr nur noch 39.000 euro wert
sind an kaufkraft dann dürfen sie doch
nicht so besteuert werden als wären es
noch 43.000 euro es ungerecht und dass
das beseitigt wird ist ein guter schritt
ich habe daraus aber eins gelernt da das
so umstritten war sogar einzelne stimmen
der unionsfraktion haben das kritisch
gesehen sozialdemokraten und grüne auch
da das so umstritten war bin ich
inzwischen folgender meinung wenn der
regelsatz für die grundsicherung bei den
menschen die nicht arbeiten regelmäßig
an die inflation
automatisch angepasst wird dann muss
auch der tarif der lohn und
einkommenssteuer zukünftig automatisch
an die inflation angepasst werden also
tarif auf rädern
[Applaus]
klare konkrete forderungen herr minister
noch einmal zurück zu dem gas und den
strompreisen die laut umfragen das thema
jetzt nur mal einzeln kalte progression
haben sie hier sicherlich viele
unterstützung gaspreis deckel auch der
soll jetzt mit einer kommission kommen
während es in europa durchaus schon
modelle gibt ihr fraktionschef im
bundestag christian dürr hat jetzt
neulich gesagt im bundestag das könnte
ungefähr 38 milliarden euro kosten wer
soll das bezahlen also da scheint sich
der nächste konflikt bei diesen noch zu
definierenden gaspreis deckel eigentlich
schon zu zeigen oder ich mache eine
kurze bemerkung vorab und dann komme ich
genau auf die frage zu sprechen
denn wir müssen miteinander sehr klar
und ehrlich sein damit auch die deutsche
wirtschaft weiß was sie zu erwarten hat
und wo es eher keine hoffnung gibt dass
muss man ganz klar sagen wir haben in
der letzten woche eine historische
zinserhöhung der europäischen
zentralbank
gesehen die ezb hat eine große
verantwortung genauso unabhängig ist sie
aber auch die inflation zu bekämpfen und
nun gibt es diesen zinsschritt
dadurch wird deutlich dass die
europäische zentralbank die inflation
als ein enormes risiko für die weitere
wirtschaftliche entwicklung sieht ich
auch robert habeck sprach hier eben von
rezession ich sage ihnen hier ganz offen
ich fürchte die lösung der
inflationserwartung aus der verankerung
fürchte ich mehr als eine technische
rezession weil dann kriegen wir den
geist nicht mehr in die flasche zurück
ein verarmungsprogramm für die menschen
der preis kann seine allokation wirkung
nicht mehr entfalten
man hält sie zurück bei unternehmerische
risiko übernahmen und investitionen die
bekämpfung der inflation muss erste
priorität haben wenn aber die ezb den
zins erhöht und straft er brücker dann
kann ich doch als finanzminister nicht
gleichzeitig an einer expansiven
finanzpolitik festhalte müsse sie mir
sagen würde habe ja dann sage ich ihm
auch also ideen die binnennachfrage zu
stärken
das ist in einem inflationsszenario
gerade nicht die richtige antwort waren
es würde sonst die staatliche
fiskalpolitik
regelmäßig die geldpolitik der notenbank
kontakt wir brauchen jetzt starke nerven
in dieser situation um die inflation zu
bekämpfen das geht nicht durch expansive
fiskalpolitik sondern durch sehr
gezielte maßnahmen die eben nicht die
preise anheizen wenn man rezession
verhindern will habe ich einen anderen
vorschlag über
andere instrumente nachzudenken statt
nur auf subventionen und hilfe zu setzen
wie wärs mal planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren beschleunigen
nicht immer mehr bürokratie wie beim
lieferketten gesetz sondern mal weniger
bürokratie da liegen doch maßnahmen der
wirtschaftsförderung die nichts kosten
fachkräfte einwanderungsgesetze fallen
mir viele dinge ein die wir tun können
die wellen langfrist nicht die
wachstumsdynamik stadt schön an ihren
forderungen der letzten drei minuten ist
ja sie regieren ja etwas machen wir das
jetzt könnt ihr das macht jetzt im
herbst kommt kommt genau dass es
gestatten sie eine wirkung also noch
genau die bemerkung zum gaspreis deckel
darüber ist keine entscheidung getroffen
worden verwechseln jetzt forderungen aus
der opposition und gehen ist ein papier
aus pausa das was da steht nichts von
einer kompression eingerichtet die dafür
sorgen sollte aber nicht ein gaspreis
deckel es gibt keine festlegungen auf
instrumente und das ist mir auch wichtig
hier zu sagen beim strom haben wir ein
instrument
strompreis bremse beim gas halten haben
wir es zu tun mit einem preis der sie
auf den weltmärkten bildet also einen
deckel zu beschließen bedeutet zunächst
einmal in lieferbeziehungen und verträge
einzugreifen oder subventionen zu zahlen
da stoßen wir schnell an die grenzen
dessen was dies kalisch möglich ist
mindestens eins können wir aber jetzt
machen das will ich bei jeder
öffentlichen gelegenheit auch betonen
wir haben mit viel von ihrem geld
15 milliarden euro um genau zu sein
die gasspeicher gefüllt mit öffentlichen
mitteln deshalb sind die jetzt so stark
gefüllt ist ihr geld der staat gemacht
durch den einkauf ist aber natürlich
auch zusätzliche knappheit in den
gasmarkt gekommen und der preis ist
gestiegen und deshalb müssen jetzt
jeden tag signale gesendet werden dass
der staat nicht nur die speicher gefüllt
um das angebot dadurch verknappt sondern
wir müssen jetzt signale in den markt
geben dass sie auch wieder aus speichern
dass wir auch im januar und vielleicht
schon im dezember im februar aus dem
staatlichen stromspeicher den markt
wieder versorgen auch das trägt dazu bei
dass sich das preisniveau in deutschland
normalisiert dann hat man dann hat man
im april oder so vielleicht wieder in 20
prozent füllstände hast du dieselbe
debatte dann wieder dass du jetzt wieder
teurer gas einkauf muss und das wahre
problem kommen dabei haben danach wir
haben dann hoffentlich auch in einem
größeren umfang importe über die lng
terminals wo ich sage gottlob dass wir
sie endlich haben das war eine debatte
über zehn jahre wo es hieß wir brauchen
sie nicht
schwamm drüber jetzt bekommen wir sie
und sie sind auch sicherlich sehr
willkommen jetzt nochmal stresstest herr
lindner wie kann es eigentlich sein dass
dort der vizekanzler robert habeck und
dann der vize vizekanzler christian
lindner in einem so was gibt es nicht
also es gibt eine wunderbare
formulierung
keine operette der bundesfinanzminister
mit besonderer erwähnung in der
geschäftsordnung der bundesregierung
jedenfalls sitzt ihnen besitzen sie
beide zusammen im kabinett und der eine
sagt stresstest licht vor
promillebereich bringt alles nichts
machen wir nicht notfallreserve der
andere sagt stresstest liegt vor wir
müssen nicht nur diese drei sondern am
besten auch noch die drei im vergangenen
jahr abgeschalteten haben das sagen das
ist nicht meine position auch mancher
niedersächsische fdp habe momentan also
meine probleme ihre die 3 meine position
ist meine position ist alle kapazitäten
sichern alle kohle ans netz kernenergie
weiter im markt lassen nicht nur wegen
der physikalischen netzstabilität
sondern ausdrücklich auch weil
zusätzliche kapazität im markt an der
strombörse handelbar ist und das
preisniveau reduziert also robert habeck
hat vorgestellt einen physikalischen
stresstester oder hat gesagt auch den
preis wirkung ist nicht so wie ich sie
gefragt hatte offenbar da gibt es
unterschiedliche einschätzungen will ich
mal sehr
vorsichtig sagen ich kenne aus der
energiewirtschaft auch andere
einschätzungen dazu und ich glaube dass
jede gesicherte kapazität uns in diesen
zeiten hilft übrigens auch im gespräch
mit unseren europäischen nachbarn und
freunden die unsere energiepolitischen
entscheidungen weniger denn je verstehen
können wenn ich das so diplomatisch
ausdruck sich vorsichtig sie geworden
sind ja ich mir geht es ja nicht darum
anderen das leben schwer zu machen es
ist doch völlig klar dass dem robert
habeck es schwerfällt über die frage
kernenergie zu sprechen ist doch völlig
klar und geht ja nicht darum jetzt man
sich wechselseitig das leben schwer
macht und die die politische
auseinandersetzung damit fliegt sondern
es geht jetzt hier um eine
krisensituation
es geht um eine zeit bis
2024 sohn läuft ja die gasanlage auch
noch also offensichtlich ist dass bisher
die politische veranschlagung dass man
bis dahin mit knappheiten zu tun hat
dann ist mein rad alles tun um jede form
von knappheit auch mit backups zu
verhindern und das hat mit sicherheit
auch eine preisdämpfende wirkung wie
kommt das gibt eben unterschiedliche
bewertungen des stresstests der vorliegt
das ist ja dann am ende auch eine
politische bewertung eines dokuments und
seiner auswirkungen am ende des tages
gibt es einen politisch verantwortlichen
fachminister
der hat dafür die expertise ich sage aus
meiner ökonomischen perspektive auch die
sollte idealerweise einbezogen die
ergebnisse haben sie schon auch gelesen
ja ich habe sie genau wahrgenommen und
füge deshalb die den appell zu einem
ökonomischen stresstest hinzu bleibt es
denn bei der notfallreserve oder kann es
sein dass sagen wir mal nach dem 9
oktober auf jeden fall später im herbst
doch noch mal ein comeback dieser akw
kommt oder war es das jetzt wir haben in
der bundesregierung dazu bislang keine
abschließende entscheidung getroffen das
ist noch zu besprechen und kann nur
hinzufügen
man muss lage adäquat reagieren
die lage ist so dass man nichts
ausschließen sollte sondern alles was
man hat das hat man der länder zum
schluss eine persönliche frage an den
fdp-vorsitzenden ich darf
wenn man sich ihre fragen sonst nun aber
sie wissen nicht was jetzt kommt
deswegen wurde ich ganz freundlich
einleiten nein im ernst sie haben viele
positionen in den vergangenen monaten
öffentlich dargestellt die aus meiner
sicht sie könnten widerspreche
fundamental anders sind als das was spd
kabinetts partner stichwort bürgergeld
grünen kabinetts pater stichwort gas
umlage akw machen wollen also da ist
vielleicht ja auch unterschiede
herangehensweise andere gewinn steuer
kalte progression sogenanntes
dienstwagen abschaffen sie kennen die
viel besser als ich diese punkte
deswegen habe ich haben sie manchmal in
ihren alten satz gedacht er vielleicht
sogar doch richtig ist lieber gar nicht
regieren als schlecht regieren nein habe
ich nicht
das habe ich nicht
habe ich nicht es gab ja keine
alternative
2017 gab es eine große koalition wir
sind in diese ampel koalition mit zwei
parteien links der mitte eingetreten ich
sage es auch in anwesenheit meines
freundes friedrich merz wegen der
regierungs unwilligkeit insbesondere der
csu und markus söders deshalb wegen der
anerkennung der politischen realitäten
sind wir in diese koalition eingetreten
jeden tag führen wir auch öffentlich
neue koalitionsgespräche
ob die dienstwagen nicht doch anders
besteuert werden sollen 6,5 millionen
neue fahrtenbuch schreiber in
deutschland übrigens auch jetzt nicht
unbedingt ökologisch oder ob nicht doch
noch eine steuer erhöht werden soll
jeden tag aufs neue führen wir das auf
und dennoch sage ich in abwandlung des
satzes von damals es ist besser für eine
fdp es ist besser für die fdp und das
land dafür zu sorgen dass es aus der
mitte regiert wird als zuzuschauen wie
das land ohne fdp nach links geführt
wird herr linder vielen dank zum
[Applaus]
eine frage aus dem publikum nochmals
abbitte für christian lettner
[Musik]
lieber herr lindner eine steuer- und
sozialversicherungsfrei inflations
prämie ist sicher zu begrüßen was aber
raten sie denjenigen unternehmen die
sich eine einmalzahlung aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen überhaupt nicht
erlauben können oder vielleicht noch
viel wichtiger was raten sie deren
mitarbeiter
ja wir haben ja eine eine toolbox jetzt
genutzt um von der dämpfung der kalten
progression über einmalzahlungen die
zwei jahre vorgezogene steuerfreiheit
der
rentenversicherungsbeiträge insgesamt zu
einer entlastung zu kommen und in diesem
instrumentenkasten spielt die steuer und
sozialversicherungsabgaben freie
einmalzahlung auch eine rolle ich höre
von vielen betrieben dass sie davon auch
gebrauch machen wollen möglicherweise
kann das auch ein bestandteil in
gesprächen mit den gewerkschaften seien
um in dieser schwierigen phase
einen gemeinsamen grund zu finden ich
erinnere mich daran dass die ig bce in
diesem jahr bereits mehr über dieses
instrument gesprochen hat aber es wird
kein instrument des staates und der
politik geben dass genau die
betriebliche wirklichkeit eines jeden
einzelnen unternehmens ansprechen kann
das wird nicht gehen und wenn ich so
offen und ehrlich sein darf die
erwartung an die politik in jedem
einzelnen unternehmen auch die ideale
situation herbeizuführen und jede form
von belastung und entscheidungs
notwendigkeit zurückzunehmen das ist
eine vollkommene überforderung nicht nur
unseres staates sondern auch eine
vollkommene überforderung der ordnung
der sozialen marktwirtschaft selbst das
kann sie nicht leisten herr lindner
herr bundesminister der finanzen
finanzen vielen dank dass sie da waren
bis zum nächsten mal vielen dank
hausgemacht tschüss auf wiedersehen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
meine damen und herren die gnade der
späten rede hat jetzt der
fraktionsvorsitzende der cdu csu im
bundestag der oppositionsführer denn er
kann auf das reagieren was hier gerade
gehört hat freue mich sehr dass er hier
ist herzlich willkommen friedrich merz
lieber herr merz sie haben robert habeck
gehört sich an christian lindner gehört
schlafen sie jetzt etwas besser vor
diesem harten winter
warum nicht wahr war das nicht schlüssig
was da in sachen strompreis und gaspreis
jetzt doch wuchtig kommen soll
die koalition ringt seit wochen um die
richtigen antworten auf ein problem das
uns seit monaten
bekannt ist und jenseits aller details
ich bedauere dass wir jetzt schon im
september sind und immer noch keine
entscheidung getroffen worden sind das
hätte nach meinem geschmack früher
stattfinden müssen sie haben viele
punkte gemacht vergangene woche auch im
bundestag was ist der zentrale aus sicht
des oppositionsführers um das thema
energie preise jetzt so schnell wie
möglich zu senken den die
bundesregierung eigentlich hätte auch
längst umsetzen können ich lasse mal den
halbsatz weg die die bundesregierung
hätte umsetzen können sondern kommen mal
auf den grund des problems
der grund dieses problems ist der krieg
in der ukraine
und dieser krieg dauert länger als
erwartet
und er hat auch eine wendung genommen
die anders ist als erwartet wir sehen in
den letzten tagen offensichtlich
nicht nur taktische sondern strategische
geländegewinne der ukrainischen armee
und jetzt komme ich auf ihren halbsatz
ich hätte mir gewünscht und ich weiß
dass die fdp dieser meinung ist ich weiß
dass große teile der grünen dieser
meinung sind sogar teile der spd wir
ohnehin ich hätte mir gewünscht dass
deutschland und europa der ukraine noch
mehr geholfen hätten wir wären
vielleicht heute schon einen schritt
weiter in der beendigung dieses krieges
ihre
position zur ukraine ist ist klar und
auch frühzeitig klargemacht worden
trotzdem auch die umfrage des bda hat
gezeigt ja wir stehen an der seite der
ukraine aber wir haben jetzt gerade ganz
konkrete existenzielle sorgen als
deutsche industrie als mittelstand und
die liegen in den energiepreisen und in
den in den immer noch steigenden strom-
und gaspreisen also was kann die
bundesregierung auf nationaler ebene
vielleicht tun um hier spürbar schnell
entlastung zu sorgen dieser
gas krieg ist ein angebotsschock für die
energiemärkte und damit auch für uns und
christian lindner hat es gerade hier
gesagt ich will es ausdrücklich
unterstreichen einen angebotsschock
begegnet man durch die erhöhung des
angebots
und ich will dann an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich dem widersprechen dass der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hier gesagt
hat die zahlen stimmen nicht wir haben
ein zu knappes energieangebot
deutschland hat im jahr 2022 mehr gas
verströmt als in den vorjahren die
gasverstromung ist nach oben gegangen
obwohl sie eigentlich hätte gesenkt
werden sollen und wir haben eine endlose
diskussion über die weiternutzung der
kernenergie
wir haben sehr spät kohle kraftwerke
wieder ans netz genommen auch das hätte
früher geschehen können müssen sie ich
finde und man muss eben auf der
angebotsseite mal den anteil der
kernenergie richtig einschätzen den wir
haben wir versorgen dieses land ungefähr
fünf bis sechs prozent im strombedarf
mit kernenergie das sind die letzten
drei verbliebenen kraftwerke und die
haben eine nennleistung von ungefähr 1,5
gigawatt pro kraftwerk das heißt wir
sind bei ungefähr 4 bis 4,5 gigawatt
umgerechnet zehn millionen haushalte die
damit sicher mit strom versorgt werden
und es erschließt sich mir offen
gestanden nur aus einem grund dass da so
gezögert wird und den respektiere ich
aber ich akzeptiere ihn nicht dass die
grünen jetzt noch einmal nachdem sie in
der außenpolitik in der
verteidigungspolitik beachtliche
schritte getan haben und sich mit der
wirklichkeit jetzt arrangiert haben auch
in dieser frage noch einmal den sprung
machen und sagen wir können nicht anders
ich gebe zu das ist ein teil des
gründungsmythos der grünen aber dieses
land kann nicht allein vom
gründungsmythos der grünen abhängig
bleiben wenn es um die energieversorgung
geht er merzig ja
[Applaus]
mich lässt die debatte zwischen ratlos
zurück weil weniger beck hier steht und
sagt nein es ist schlicht nicht
parteipolitisch geprägt ich habe mir das
angeschaut bei der versorgungssicherheit
sieht er das offenbar anders und sie
aber auch bei den preisen gibt es auch
natürlich energiewirtschaftliche
institute die sagen das sei
vernachlässigbar der milderung effekt
was sollen die bürger was soll die
wirtschaft denn jetzt glauben dass der
wirtschaftsminister der sagt dass es
sachlich und faktisch da ist der
oppositionsführer sagt das stimmt so
nicht also der nächste schritt hin zu
mehr klarheit wäre das mal die
kalkulationsgrundlagen für die gasanlage
veröffentlicht werden die kennen wir bis
heute nicht und das auch mal
veröffentlicht wird was eigentlich in
diesen stresstest gestanden hat die sind
ja auch nicht veröffentlicht worden in
auszügen schon aber im gesamten wortlaut
nicht so warum werden die die grünen
sind die partei der transparenz die sie
immer und überall fordern warum werden
diese zahlen und diese daten jetzt nicht
mal transparent gemacht und da muss ich
noch mal christian lindner recht geben
wir reden hier nicht nur über einen
belastungstest für das netz und für die
netzstabilität das ist nur ein aspekt
der wichtigere aspekt wäre jetzt darüber
zu reden wie viel kapazitäten haben wir
eigentlich strom
erzeugungskapazitäten wenn man in einer
solchen lage ist wie in der wir jetzt
sind muss man wirklich sagen volle kraft
voraus für alle kapazitäten die wir
haben und an keiner stelle noch aus
welchen gründen auch immer auf die
bremse treten übrigens wenn wir das
nicht jetzt endlich machen dann wird die
europäische solidarität erheblich
bröckeln wir liefern zurzeit nach
frankreich weil die franzosen wie in
jedem sommer auch in diesem sommer einen
teil ihrer kraftwerke abschalten aber in
dem augenblick wo der sommer vorbei ist
und die franzosen dann wieder umgekehrt
liefern sollen an uns werden die die
frage stellen warum sollen wir euch
eigentlich liefern wenn ihr eigene
kapazitäten die ihr habt stilllegt das
heißt da kommt ein konflikt mit unserem
wichtigsten nachbarn mit frankreich auf
die tagesordnung also meine antwort ist
alle optionen jetzt nutzen und auf keine
verzichten manche sagen dass die
französischen akw durchaus auch
inzwischen sind bröselig sind und edf
jetzt auch nicht gerade die effizientes
unternehmen ist aber dass wir es mal
dahin gestellt die akw debatte wir
kommen ja offenbar nicht weiter außer
herbert sie sagen als oppositionsführer
der in den ländern ja regiert und die
länder müssen ja zu stimmen zum vielen
dieser maßnahmen im entlastungspaket
wenn sie also sicher sind dass
deutschlands industrie nation die akw
weiter braucht müssten sie doch
eigentlich ihre zustimmung im bundesrat
daran knüpfen dass die akw länger laufen
dürfen also ich kann den
ministerpräsidenten hier nicht
vorgreifen aber sie sind sicher ein
bisschen was haben sie da auch stehen
wir mit dem ministerpräsidenten sehr eng
ab und wir sind ja auch ganz gemeinsam
auf einer linie wir werden im bundesrat
natürlich über die entlastungs pakete zu
sprechen haben die länder fühlen sich im
augenblick und zwar unabhängig von jeder
partei politischen zugehörigkeit von der
bundesregierung vor vollendete tatsachen
gestellt
auch da vielleicht nur noch mal eine
einen hinweis auf einige zahlen
christian lindner hat das eben aus der
sicht des bundeshaushalt richtig
beschrieben aber die länderhaushalte
sind in gleichem umfang betroffen die
mehreinnahmen fließen auch den ländern
zu aber die länder werden nicht gefragt
wenn es um die ausgaben geht also es
wird hier schon im herbst eine
gemeinsame verabredung zwischen bund und
ländern geben müssen auch da hätte ich
mir gewünscht dass wir das früher
gemacht hätten zur erinnerung herr
brücker wir haben markus söder und ich
der bundesregierung angeboten in den
sommerferien eine bundestagssitzung zu
machen das atomgesetz zu ändern
brennstäbe zu bestellen damit man eben
nicht nur mit den alten brennstäben
weiterarbeiten muss der streck betrieb
hilft uns nicht sondern dass wir
wenigstens für zwei drei jahre diese
kraftwerke am netz lassen noch mal damit
klar ist nicht zurück zur alten
kernenergie das will keiner von uns aber
das was wir haben jetzt nicht aus der
hand geben
unabhängig von der akw debatte herr merz
wo sind die maßnahmen wo sie im
entlastungspaket sagen da müssen wir
dringend nachbessern nach steuern wenn
es um die entlastung des mittelstands
der industrie geht also zunächst einmal
wäre gut wenn von anfang an die rentner
die studenten und der mittelstand
überhaupt beachtet worden wären bei
diesen entlastungspaket und schritten
sind doch leider werden jetzt das wird
jetzt nachgeholt also sie mal den anfang
vergessen worden jetzt ist am
mittelstand vergessen worden das wird
jetzt auch hoffentlich nachgeholt ich
würde hier auch auf der angebotsseite
zunächst versuchen eine antwort zu geben
und wir haben den vorschlag gemacht nach
rücksprache nach intensiven debatten mit
der energiewirtschaft
dass wir sagen wir sollten beim gas
erwägen das ist ein markteingriff der
natürlich erwogen werden muss und der
nicht unkritisch ist aber wir sollten
beim gas erwägen hier den
großhandelspreis zu deckeln und zwar
ganz unabhängig davon woher das gas
kommt in den markt eingreifen und sagen
wir deckeln den großhandelspreis bei
einem bestimmten niveau damit das nicht
weiter durch die decke geht sage dass
sozialisten als unbezahlbar das weiß ich
nicht ob das unbezahlbar ist es ist ja
die frage ob man das ausgleichen muss
oder nicht wir haben den vorschlag
gemacht das muss man besprechen
diskutieren aber das ist aus unserer
sicht eine möglichkeit die zweite
möglichkeit wäre die entkopplung im
merit order system das man also den
gaspreis rausnimmt aus der
preisgestaltung der energie was europa
jetzt vorhat naja was hat europa vor
europa hat jetzt vor ich lese in den
zeitungen dass sie ein gesetz machen
wollen zur abschöpfung von einem drittel
der sogenannten über gewinne also da
wünsche ich der europäischen union aber
wirklich gute reise erstens mal machen
die keine gesetze sondern richtlinien
und verordnungen und ob sie überhaupt
eine kompetenz dazu haben so etwas zu
tun und dann rechtsverbindlich für alle
mitgliedstaaten vorzuschreiben das wird
noch eine spannende diskussion mir wäre
es lieber wenn man so in den markt
eingreift dass diese über gewinne erst
überhaupt nicht in dem umfang entstehen
dann brauchte man sie auch nicht
abzuschöpfen und zurück zu fassen es
jetzt zu spät und ich verstehe das weiß
ich nicht ob das zu spät ist ja schon
welche angefallen sind natürlich
milliarden angefallen aber noch mal es
wird eine sehr schwierige definition
geben und die wird natürlich angegriffen
haben es eben gehört in italien wird
geklagt in spanien wird geklagt dass
rechtssicher auszuformulieren gibt weder
für den nationalen gesetzgeber noch für
den europäischen gesetzgeber dafür eine
blaupause das kann man überlegen nur
löst das wirklich heute das problem ich
glaube es nicht besser wäre jetzt den
markteingriff beim merit order und mit
einer entsprechenden deckelung der
großhandelspreise damit wird man
wahrscheinlich bessere ergebnisse
erzielen als mit dem abschöpfen dieser
sogenannten was national möglich wäre
und wie viel kosten würde das ist schwer
zu berechnen ich sage nochmal wir müssen
nach meiner einschätzung das nicht
kompensieren wenn man in den markt mit
einer solchen maßnahmen greift auch das
merit order system löst nicht
kompensations forderungen das ist ein
markt system das sich bewährt hat bis zu
dem zeitpunkt dieses angebot shops also
muss man noch die frage stellen muss man
dieses markt design ändern und wenn die
bundesregierung auf dem weg ist und hwk
ziel gesagt das mag design zu ändern
dann sind wir sehr offen für diese
diskussion dadurch von uns keinen
widerspruch gegeben wenn es vernünftig
gemacht wir können einige energiehändler
nicht mehr weiter agieren weil sie diese
preise die sie zum einkaufen und
bezahlen müssten dann aber so nicht
weiter gehen können und dafür nicht
kompensiert werden jetzt sind vorbei
aber bei einem anderen thema jetzt sind
wir bei der frage wie löst man das
problem zum beispiel mit juniper und
einigen wenigen anderen die davon
betroffen sind dass sie die preise die
sie bezahlen müssen an ihre kunden
weitergeben können da sage ich ihnen da
ist das system gas umlage aus unserer
sicht die falsche antwort erstes mal
wirkt diese gasanlage inflationstreibend
wir reden hier über 35 milliarden euro
auf jahresbasis das treibt die inflation
zusätzlich nach oben belastet sehr viele
unternehmen sehr viele private haushalte
wir halten sie für falsch besser wäre
wir haben erfahrung damit schutzschirme
zu machen so wie wir das in der kroner
krise so wie wir das auch in der
finanzkrise mit den banken gemacht haben
staatliche schutzschirme über diese
unternehmen und dann bitte auch in der
haftung kaskade erst das eigenkapital
dann das fremdkapital und dann der start
ich finde es schön herr merz jetzt als
verstaatlichungs befürworter sind womit
wir genau beim thema sind dem cdu
vorsitz den vergleich mehr zu dem ich
jetzt kommen würde lassen sie es einfach
mal so stehen in der das tue ich nicht
aber das widerspricht gleich
ich habe ihren cdu-parteitag ich hab
schon fast gesagt bewundert verfolgt
wollte ich eigentlich sagen herr merz
sagen sie ruhig begleitet und auch ihre
rede gehört und habe mich gefragt nach
nach dieser leidenschaftlichen debatte
auch zur frauenquote und zur
gleichstellung die dann auch so kam wie
sie es ja auch wollten und ihrer rede in
der sehr viel ukraine und auch da ihre
klare position vor kam auch ein bisschen
kritik am öffentlich-rechtlichen
rundfunk aber was ich vermisst habe merz
und so habe ich sie kennen lernt ist der
sozialpolitische wirtschaftspolitische
reformer friedrich merz wo ist der
eigentlich geblieben oder kommt er
nächstes jahr also zunächst einmal haben
wir einen wirklich guten bundesparteitag
der cdu am letzten freitag und samstag
gehabt der ist gut vorbereitet gewesen
wir haben eine ganze reihe von fragen
auf die tagesordnung gesetzt unter
anderem einen umfangreichen leitantrag
des bundesvorstandes den wir noch in der
woche zuvor erarbeitet haben und der ist
mit einigen kleineren ergänzungen
verabschiedet worden das war nur
energiepolitik und nur
wirtschaftspolitiker die thema
gesprochen über die themen haben wir
gerade gesprochen und wir behandeln
natürlich auf solche einem parteitag
zunächst einmal auch sehr aktuelle
themen die müssen wir behandeln da
müssen wir eine antwort auch für die
bevölkerung geben wo wir dastehen wir
hatten einen alten posten den wir
beschließen mussten das war dieses thema
frauenquote ich habe in meiner rede zu
dieser debatte gesagt wir machen da
einen winzig kleinen schritt in wahrheit
ist das keine quote sondern letztlich
eine kleine änderung in der
zusammensetzung der vorstände die in der
cdu gewählt werden wenn genug frauen
kandidieren so das ist eine völlig
überhöhte debatte gewesen nach meinem
empfinden ist da ein ein kulturkampf
teilweise daraus gemacht worden in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung der völlig
neben der sache liegt das war eine
entscheidung dieser drei jahren dafür
wurde aber leidenschaftlich dass jahren
das ist ja das ist das was ich an diesem
parteitag besonders gut findet dass die
cdu ihre fähigkeit zurück gewonnen hat
leidenschaftlich zu diskutieren und das
war für ehrlich gesagt für mich das
wichtigste ziel auf diesem parteitag
dass wir endlich mal wieder rauskommen
aus dieser stromlinienförmigen befolgung
dessen was da eine regierung tut und die
partei läuft hinterher das ist vorbei
wir wir führen jetzt wieder sehr
leidenschaftliche debatten so und diese
debatten haben auch zum beispiel zum
thema soziales pflichtjahr stattgefunden
das war eine hochspannende hoch
interessante diskussion von der ich mich
auch habe bewegen lassen der sache
zuzustimmen obwohl ich am anfang
eigentlich eher skeptisch war ich war
nicht davon überzeugt die debatte hat
mich überzeugt dass es richtig ist jetzt
einen solchen weg zu gehen so und die
nächsten themen werden kommen wir haben
eine große frage das will ich hier bei
der bda mal sagen wir haben eine große
frage vertagt weil es dafür einfach
zeitlich nicht reichte wir mussten noch
einmal über das thema tarifautonomie und
flächen bindung oder bindung der
tarifverträge sprechen da kann ich ihm
verbindlich sagen das wird so wie es da
vorgelegt worden ist mit mir nicht
kommen so wir werden diese eingriffe in
die tarifautonomie sowie das aus einem
kleinen teil der partei vorgeschlagen
ist nicht machen die diskussion werden
wir aber führen dieser parteitag ist
eine zwischenetappe gewesen auf dem weg
zum ziel und da sind wir einen großen
schritt weiter
beim letzten eingriff in die
tarifautonomie im bundestag bei gesetz
zum 12 euro mindestlohn darum sich
enthalten
habe ich auch eine alte last übernehmen
müssen aus dem letzten wahl jahr da war
die union nicht klar genug und es gab in
der bundestagsfraktion darüber sehr
harte auseinandersetzungen wir haben den
mantel falsche eingeköpft wir haben die
diskussion nicht am anfang geführt
sondern am ende und deswegen hat aus
meiner sicht am ende nur noch die
möglichkeit gegeben dass wir uns
enthalten weil wir gesagt haben dass wir
diesen eingriff in die tarifautonomie
ich wollen niemand hat von uns infrage
gestellt dass zwölf euro mindestlohn
angemessen sind aber auch da kann ich
ihnen zu sagen wenn wir noch einmal eine
solche debatte führen wird der mantel
richtig ein geknüpft und dann wird auch
eine richtige antwort gegeben was ich
vermisst habe ist auch einsatz und wir
machen es zum abschluss herz zu den zur
zukunft der sozialsysteme der
arbeitgeberpräsident hat heute morgen in
seiner rede die 3d genannt wie über
einige haben wir gesprochen
deindustrialisierung war jetzt thema in
den letzten minuten die die
globalisierung war auch thema im panel
mit den botschaftern aber die
demographie war gar nicht thema und ich
frage mich warum wir nicht und wenn
nicht von ihnen von wem denn dann über
die reform der sozialsysteme mit klaren
antworten und auch ermutigen botschaften
reden sei es das rentenalter an die
lebenserwartung zu koppeln aber da kommt
aus meiner sicht auch gerade aus ihrer
partei gar nichts mehr das ist für den
augenblick vielleicht ein eindruck den
sie von außen haben in wahrheit arbeiten
wir an diesem thema sehr intensiv ich
will allerdings auch dazu sagen ich habe
mich immer gewehrt gegen plakative
einzelforderungen dann haben wir sofort
in diesem land ein massives verletzungs
potenzial in der öffentlichkeit also
nehmen wir mal an ich hätte das gesagt
was sie mir hier gerade vorschlagen dass
einheimische vor sich dann hätte ich
sofort eine riesen debatte in der
öffentlichkeit gehabt märz für höheres
renteneintrittsalter das ist nicht die
lösung des problems allein wir müssen
hier wirklich an die grundlagen unserer
sozialversicherung gehen und ich habe
das der partei mehrfach gesagt die
intellektuell anspruchsvollste leistung
die wir zu erbringen haben ist ein
reformvorschlag für die gesetzliche
rentenversicherung die wir im augenblick
in einer verfassung sehen dass sie ohne
ständig weiter steigenden zuschuss aus
dem bundeshaushalt nicht überleben ich
habe herr merz was los mit ihnen nur
weil eine debatte so laufen könnte wie
sie es nicht möchten und journalisten
etwas zuspitzen sagen sie nein das was
sie wirklich denken ich sage dass das
thema
lebensarbeitszeit allein das problem
nicht löse sie war wurde gesagt ich
möchte dass wir uns die zeit nehmen und
da lasse ich mich auch von keinem
journalisten unter druck setzen ich
möchte dass wir uns die zeit nehmen
einen vernünftigen vorschlag zu machen
der allumfassend dieses problem für die
zukunft löst und ich sage ihnen das wird
verdammt schwierig und mit einzelnen
überschriften nicht zu lösen sein aber
dass wir die neue finanzierung brauchen
aber sonst einigen absolut dass wir auch
höhere eigenbeiträge brauchen dass wir
eine sehr viel stärkere kapitaldeckung
der altersversorgung brauchen ist
vollkommen unstreitig aber das wirklich
in ein gesamtkonzept zu bringen das
erfordert zeit ich erinnere mich daran
wir haben die zeit uns in der union
schon mal genommen ich war mitglied der
hat zur kommission vor 20 jahren da
haben wir uns die zeit genommen und
diese zeit müssen wir uns jetzt wieder
nehmen und wir nehmen sie uns und das
das bürgergeld was übermorgen
beschlossen wird im kabinett kein
instrument ist zur anreiz für
arbeitsaufnahme das würden sie sagen
oder
es hat ja mit diesem thema überhaupt
nichts zu tun das ist genau das
gegenteil von dem was wir eigentlich
bräuchten mit diesem bürgergeld wird der
eindruck erweckt als ob wir sozusagen in
das bedingungslose grundeinkommen
einsteigen das ist bei der
grundsicherung bei der
kindergrundsicherung jetzt kommen wir
mit dem bürgergeld also das kann ich für
die union verbindlich sagen diesen weg
in ein bedingungsloses grundeinkommen
aus öffentlichen kassen den geht die
union nicht mit das kann nicht
verbindlich sagt klartext
zum schluss
und wenn sich im märz von einem
journalisten nicht unter druck setzen
lassen wir dann von mir insofern kein
problem jetzt zum abschluss lieber herr
merz noch eine frage aus dem publikum
was abbitte
funktioniert nicht mehr gut da haben wir
glück gehabt dass wir längst es gibt
auch das stets auch herr brückner es
gibt keinen ein spieler das ist eine
ziemlich klare botschaft da haben sie
mir aber auch sagen können sie alles
gesehen man muss nur lesen können
ich bedanke mich sehr dass sie da waren
vielen dank dass wir hier oben haben und
ich übergebe wieder an
ja das war der arbeitgebertag zumindest
teile davon in berlin wir wollen das
ganze natürlich noch einordnen mit
emanuel richter politikwissenschaftler
der rwth in aachen herr richter ich
grüße sie
sie haben das ganze mit uns verfolgt
starten wir vorne eine strompreis bremse
bis zum ende des jahres soll es geben
das hat der wirtschaftsminister habe
gesagt das ganze wird ja auch auf
europäischer ebene diskutiert die ganze
zeit hieß es immer nationaler alleingang
in dieser sache könnte risikoreich sei